Let's get started.
One announcement. And that is that
a reminder about the celebration of
learning on Wednesday,
October 2nd, Test 2. It will have
coverage spanning lectures 7 through
17. The new material that I am
going to introduce today will not be
covered, but certainly this little
review is worthwhile.
And going back to 7 with the
beginning of ionics.
What I wanted to do today was just
set the stage and briefly review
where we were last day where we
looked at the emission spectrum of a
target in an x-ray tube.
Here I have plotted intensity
versus wavelength.
Long wavelength is low energy.
Energy is increasing from right to
left. And what we see is a family
of nested curves each taking a
different plate voltage.
Low voltage gives us low intensity.
High voltage gives us high
intensity. We see this whale-shaped
background which we refer to as the
continuous spectrum or
"bremsstrahlung.
And then once we reach a critical
voltage beyond which we start to see
this second set of lines here,
which I have indicated in fuchsia.
And this is the characteristic
spectrum, and it is quantized.
It is not continuous. We have
discrete values of wavelength
associated with energy transitions
within the target.
And those transitions are prompted
by the ejection of inner shell
electrons. And that does not occur
until you get to a certain critical
plate voltage which translates into
a certain critical ballistic energy
on the part of the incident
electrons. And there are a few
features here that we can point out.
The various discrete wavelengths of
the characteristic spectrum are
calculable, the k alpha
and the l alpha.
Lines are calculable by Mosley's law,
which is given here,
where the nf and ni are associated
with a particular transition.
For k lines it is the transition
from two to one.
And screening factor is one for the
k alpha transition.
For the l alpha transition it is
from three to two.
And the screening factor in that
case is 7.4. We can calculate these
discrete values.
And the other point that we can
calculate on this curve is the
leading edge of the continuous
spectrum. The leading edge of the
continuous spectrum is designated
here as the shortest wavelength,
which obviously is the highest
energy. And that derives from total
transfer of incident ballistic
energy of the electron to photon and
capture of the electron.
And that is the shortest wavelength
given by the Duane-Hunt law which is
12,400 over the plate voltage giving
you a value of wavelength
in angstroms.
I think we are ready now to probe
atomic arrangement with x-rays.
And, in order to do so, we are
going to rely on two important
factors. First of all,
we are going to model the crystal as
an array of mirrors.
In other words, we are going to
look at the atoms in the crystal and
consider each atom as
acting as a mirror.
This will give us features that we
can exploit in a very simple model.
Let's model atoms as mirrors. And
that is going to allow us to use the
laws of specular reflection.
And the one that we most critically
rely on is that the angle of
incidence equals the
angle of reflection.
That is the first thing that we use.
And then the second thing that we
use is interference criteria.
We are going to apply interference
criteria. Let's take a look at what
we mean by that.
We have two possibilities.
We can have multiple beams coming
in phase or we can have multiple
beams coming out of phase.
And so here is what we talk about.
I am going to show a little sketch
where I am plotting amplitude.
This is some electromagnetic signal.
Amplitude versus time.
Let's look at two rays.
Here is one. This is amplitude
versus time. And the second one,
in phase. I am going to draw it
directly beneath.
And so the crests line up,
the troughs line up. If I take ray
one plus ray two,
I am going to add them.
And I will get the intensification,
the additive sum of amplitude
because they are in phase.
This is called in phase radiation
summing. Or the other term applied
to this is constructive
interference.
That is the one extreme.
The other extreme is totally out of
phase. In that case,
ray one I will draw as I did before,
but ray two I will draw
symmetrically opposite so that in
ray two the crest of ray two aligns
with the trough of ray one.
The trough of ray two aligns with
the crest of ray one.
And, for argument's sake,
let's say that these are equal in
amplitude. If I have two rays equal
in amplitude and they interfere but
they are perfectly out of phase,
if I add these two signals what I
will get is nothing.
They will cancel. Complete
cancellation. This is called
destructive interference.
And those are the only two
principles we need.
And we can describe at a very
reasonable level what is going on
inside a crystal which is being
irradiated by electromagnetic
radiation in the x region of the
spectrum. That is all I am going to
use are these two ideas.
Let's now go to a simple model here
of a crystal. We will
draw some atoms here.
Here is the top plane.
Let's go down a second.
And I will make this cubic.
Here are two planes of atoms.
And let's say I have incident light
coming in at some angle theta.
One ray I am showing striking this
atom.
And if I observe the laws of
specular reflection,
this will reflect from the mirror at
the identical angle.
The angle of reflection equals the
angle of incidence.
And let's put a second ray coming
down here. And it,
too, will reflect at the same angle
and come out like so.
Oh, there is a cell phone.
Somebody is leaving the room.
Let's go. I want the cell phones
off. No compromises.
Show some respect for your
classmates. It is rude.
It is disrespectful to me.
It's disrespectful to the class.
You don't get it. If that happens
on Wednesday, I will tear up your
paper in front of your eyes and give
you a zero. Mark my words.
I want to look at what happens when
I have light coming in at a
particular angle.
And, furthermore,
I want to specify that I have in
phase radiation which is also termed
coherent. I have in phase incident
coherent radiation.
And, furthermore, I want it
monochromatic.
These are x-rays that are coherent
and monochromatic.
Monochromatic means a single
wavelength. Here is the incident
radiation on the left,
and this is the reflected radiation
on the right. And what do I want to
see here? I want to see what the
conditions are to give me
constructive interference because I
don't want destructive interference.
If I have destructive interference
I won't see anything.
Let's mark this by showing some kind
of a waveform.
What I will do is show just the
first sinusoid,
and then I will show the same on the
second ray. What I am trying to
indicate is that I have in phase
radiation coming down from the left.
And then over here I want to
indicate that I have in phase
radiation leaving.
Again, I will indicate the
sinusoids in the same position.
There is an issue here.
You can see ray one travels a
shorter distance than ray two.
Ray two has to go farther. I can
actually calculate how far that is.
If I drop a normal from here and a
normal from here,
I can label this A,
B and C. And we can see that ray
two has to travel a farther distance,
AB plus BC. And what is the
condition of AB plus BC to ensure
that these two are in phase?
They must equal some path length
that is a whole number of
wavelengths. Otherwise,
I will get some amount of
destructive interference.
And n, of course, is a whole number.
I don't care.
It's one, two and so on.
Actually, we can call this the
order of the reflection.
And if I go through the math,
we know what theta is. What is this
distance between successive planes?
If I am showing you adjacent hkl
planes then this distance here is d,
as we have defined it before. This
is the distance between adjacent hkl
planes. And, if I go through the
trigonometry here,
n lambda will equal two times d sine
of theta. We've got the angle theta.
We know the distance between
successive planes.
If n lambda equals 2 d sine theta,
this path length will be such that
constructive interference will occur,
in phase radiation will be reflected
as such, and this is called Bragg's
Law. It is the condition for
constructive interference
in a crystal.
And, in 3.091,
what we are going to do is neglect
higher order reflections.
In 3.091, we neglect higher order
reflections. Let's just put n
equals one. Bragg's Law for 3.
91 will simply be lambda equals 2 d
sine theta. That is
the Bragg condition.
Suppose I have a new system and I
find that I have now atoms here.
Let's say I go from a simple cubic
to a body-centered cubic.
Well, in body-centered cubic there
are atoms here.
I know they are on a different
plane relative to the board,
but relative to the horizontal there
is a plane of atoms at this location.
Let's see what happens
in this case.
In this case, if I have a third ray
that comes in,
let's call it ray three,
and ray three also is in phase with
ray one and ray two,
this is the reflected ray three,
I can define the additional path
length of ray three as DEF.
And what we see is that it turns
out then that DE plus EF,
if n equals one, this is going to be
one-half a wavelength.
If AB plus BC is one wavelength,
this is one-half wavelength. And
what that means is that the
reflected ray three is perfectly out
of phase with rays one and two.
That means we are going to get
destructive interference.
And that means,
if we park a detector right here,
we will measure zero intensity. We
measure zero intensity at that angle.
Now what I want to do is generalize
what we have observed here.
I want to generalize this analysis.
And, if I generalize this analysis,
what I get is that if I take the
interference criterion and combine
it with the crystal structure,
what does that give me? It gives me
the set of expected reflections.
And so, in essence,
this is a fingerprint of the crystal
structure. It is not a fingerprint
of the chemical identity.
It does not say anything about
identity, but any crystal structure
of this description will give the
reflections at the same
set of angles.
Any crystal structure of this
description will give no reflections
at the same set of angles.
This, for example, will show you
what would happen in the case of
.  we saw reflects in
simple cubic at the given
angle theta 001.
But it does not reflect in
body-centered cubic at theta 001.
Because in body-centered cubic
there are atoms at .
And atoms at  will be totally
out of phase with the reflection
that is coming off of .
We will see no reflection at .
Likewise, with FCC. FCC also has
atoms at the midpoint on each face.
It does not reflect in BCC and FCC,
both of them. Now I can start to
distinguish which are which.
And now let's take a look at some
opportunity to make sense of this.
Here is just a figure that I took
from one of the texts just showing
what I have drawn on the board.
I think we can zoom through this.
Now this is on the handout. This
is the selection rules for
reflection in cubic crystals.
What has happened here is that the
geometric analysis along these lines
has been performed taking into
account the atom positions.
And what do we see?
We see that simple cubic we get
reflections at every plane,
at every index. Body-centered cubic
is not reflecting the ,
because we have shown already that
the reflection from  at that
angle is perfectly out of phase.
The computations have been done.
And, likewise, FCC. This is
indicating that you won't see a
reflection in face-centered
cubic or body-centered cubic.
Then we go down to ,
simple cubic reflects, body-centered
cubic reflects,
but face-centered cubic does not
reflect. You cannot look at any
single line. You have to look at
the entire pattern and so on.
And there is a simple way of
codifying all of this.
Simple cubic, all of the indices
are reflecting.
In body-centered cubic,
if you go through this pattern,
what we are looking at is the sum of
h squared plus k squared
plus l squared.
And that gives you a nice sequence,
one, two, three, four, five and so
on. And what you see with BCC is
you have the sequence two,
four, six, eight, ten. The sum of h
plus k plus l is even.
That is a way of capturing what is
going on in this series.
And for face-centered cubic,
it turns out that the planes that
reflect are either all even numbers
or all odd numbers.
For example, face-centered cubic,
you see . Those are all odd.
. Zero is termed in this
calculation as being an even number.
Two is even, zero is even and zero
is even. Three and four reflect.
Five and six do not. Eight does.
That is  and so on, eight,
eleven, twelve,
sixteen. This is a set of selection
criteria that have been tabulated
for your convenience.
And now what we can do is go into
some example using this technique in
order to index a crystal.
And so I want to show you two
different techniques that allow us
to determine the crystal structure.
The first one is called
diffractometry.
And since it is done with x-rays,
it is also known as x-ray
diffraction, XRD.
And the characteristics of x-ray
diffraction are we use radiation of
fixed wavelength and we vary the
angle, variable angle.
Look at this cartoon here.
If we have fixed wavelength and we
are varying the angle,
I am going to be moving the crystal.
This is how I am going to get
variable angle.
What I am saying is variable angle
of incidence. In other words,
I want to probe all of the incident
angles and build a library of
responses. For a given incidence
angle, what is the intensity of the
reflected radiation?
The way I do that is to park the
beam and rotate the specimen.
Ultimately, I end up with a plot
that looks like this.
Intensity versus angle.
This is angle of reflected.
Now we are going to decide if the
pattern we observe conforms to this
set of rules up here.
And, by making that comparison,
we can deduce which of these three
crystal structures the crystal
belongs to. And I am keeping this
as a very narrow set.
I am saying this is 3.
91 so we confine ourselves to the
universe of cubic crystals.
If you want to get more general
then it could be any one of the
crystals that comes out of the 14
Bravais lattices, plus
a range of bases.
There is a huge database out there
that has values of intensity versus
angle for thousands and thousands of
metals and compounds.
A huge amount of mineralogy in this
database. And so,
when you bring a specimen of unknown
provenance, you are able to use this
technique and infer what
the constituents are.
First of all, let's take a look at
what the specimen looks like.
I cannot take a few atoms. What we
use is a powdered specimen.
We grind the material into a fine
powder and we put it in a silicate
glass holder. And a silicate glass
holder looks something like this.
It is a very narrow tube.
This is definitely not to scale.
This dimension here is about a
tenth of a millimeter.
It is a very narrow tube,
a tenth of a millimeter made of
silicate glass.
It is an oxide glass,
a cousin of window glass.
Why do we choose it? Not because
it is transparent visible light.
We don't care. We are shooting
x-rays through this thing,
for heaven's sakes. Why do we
choose this?
Because it is amorphous and it
doesn't have a crystal structure of
its own. If we are trying to
irradiate the contents of this and
the tube itself has a crystal
structure, how are we going to sort
out what is the contents from the
container. This is amorphous,
no long range order. And inside we
put little grains of powder.
The powder dimension is on the
order of about 50 micrometers.
Oh, the wall thickness,
I didn't mention that. That is one
one-hundredth of a millimeter.
Saying it is paper thin is an
exaggeration. It is one-hundredth
of a millimeter.
And this distance is about two
centimeters. You grind in a mortar
and pestle, drop the powder in here,
and this goes into the
diffractometer and is irradiated.
And we are going to turn this in
order to present as many different
angles as possible.
We have many grains in here.
Each grain, the theory is if we
grind these fine enough,
each one of these can act as a
single crystal.
Now light is coming in and
reflecting off this,
but its cousin is sitting at a
slightly different angle.
And so I am going to try to,
through the mix of powder and the
rotation of the specimen,
try to get all of the different
incident angles so that I will get
as many reflected angles as possible.
I worked with this.
It was my PhD thesis.
The material was sensitive to
moisture in the air so I had to work
in a glove box.
I had these big thick rubber gloves
on holding something like this.
Only in real life it is about this
big. And you are inside the glove
box and it's Toronto in August and
perspiration is pouring.
You are supposed to be crying now.
The perspiration is pouring down my
face. I have to get the powder to
fall in here. And I have got to
flick this a little bit.
I flick it one more time and it
breaks off.
You laugh now.
It's not funny.
That's the way. That's how science
goes. Anyway.
What happens now?
We take this. Now I am going to
give you the top view of the
diffractometer.
It is essentially the combination
of an x-ray generator,
a specimen holder and a detector.
The top view has x-ray coming in.
This is monochromatic x-ray,
some lambda fixed, coming in.
Top view has this sitting in a
carousel, and this carousel spins.
And then I have a detector. And
the detector itself moves through a
variety of angles.
And so here we have an incidence
angle and here we have a reflectance
angle. Ultimately,
we get a plot of intensity versus
reflected angle from this specimen.
That is how this thing works.
And here is what the output could
look like. You will have nothing
and then you will have peaks at
discrete lines.
Why? At certain angles the Bragg
condition is satisfied.
At other angles the Bragg condition
is not satisfied.
These are the Bragg peaks
associated with magical angles.
And what are the magical angles?
They are the angles associated with
those planes.
This is how we are trying to make
sense of what is going on here.
I wanted to give you the thrill of
discovery, so we are going to do a
virtual lab here.
What I have for you is a data set.
If you flip over your sheet, this
is all you get,
the output. Now,
for reasons I don't want to go into,
the angles are often reported as two
theta instead of theta.
And it has to do with the geometry
of this specimen and
blah, blah, blah.
But that is not important.
We have a copper target in the
x-ray generator,
which means we will have
monochromatic light lambda 1.
418 angstroms. We know that. And,
remember, we said we had to fix our
lambda. We have done that.
We have rotated the specimen
variable theta.
And these are the peaks.
I don't care about the intensities.
All I am doing right now is telling
you these are the peaks that I got.
How do we take that and infer what
the crystal is?
Well, you can go to the library and
get all these self-help books.
I have not had the time to write a
full self-help book,
but I got this one self-help sheet
here. This is my program.
You won't find this in any books.
This I am giving to you special. I
want to walk through this and show
you how to take that dataset and
index the crystal.
The question we are trying to
answer is what is the crystal
structure? And you only have three
answers. It's either going to be
simple cubic, body-centered cubic or
face-centered cubic.
And that is the dataset.
That is all you have, plus your
mind. It says start with the two
theta values and generate a set of
sine squared theta values.
Oh, I should perhaps tell you how I
came up with this,
what is the underlying principle.
Here is the underlying principle.
To solve the puzzle, all I did was
I took these two equations.
I took the Bragg's Law,
which is lambda equals 2 d sine
theta, and I took the formula for
the d spacing between planes,
which you saw two days ago, which is
the ratio of the lattice constant
divided by the sum of the squares of
the Miller Indices of the plane.
If I take those two equations and
put them together,
I can get the following relationship.
Lambda squared over 4 a squared
equals sine squared theta over h
squared plus k squared plus l
squared. Now,
look at the left side of this
equation. Lambda is the wavelength
of the incident radiation,
and that is fixed. We fixed that in
the experiment,
so this is a constant.
It is fixed. A is the lattice
constant of the crystal.
That is the crystal property,
so that is fixed. That means the
ratio of lambda squared over 4 a
squared is a constant.
Well, when I went to school,
what they taught me in math was that
if the left-hand side of the
equation is constant,
the right-hand side of the equation
is constant. That means even though
theta is varying with hkl,
this ratio varies in such a way as
to remain constant.
That is the key.
Whatever hkl is,
at that theta, the sine squared of
that angle over the h squared plus k
squared plus l squared remains
constant as you go through all of
the lines. This is the underlying
principle. Let's go into this.
The first thing I want to do is
build sine squared theta.
There they are. Those are the
theta values. And now I have taken
them, divided them by two and then
taken the sine and then squared it.
Now I have a new column.
And then it says normalize by
dividing sine squared theta by the
first member of the column.
All I did was took everything and
divided it by 0.
43. This 0.143 divided by 0.
43 is one. This is, as you can see,
0.190 divided by 0.140 is about 1.34
and so on. Why?
Because, look, I am going to this.
What is the next thing? Clear the
fractions from the normalized column.
I don't like this.
I don't like 1.
0, 1.34 and so on.
1.34 to me, allowing for some
experimental error,
is roughly one and a third.
It is roughly four-thirds. And
that is 2.67. That is roughly
eight-thirds. Why not multiply the
whole darn column by 3 and throw
away the little residuals.
And, sure enough, you get a set of
whole numbers,
3, 4, 8, 11, 12 and so on.
This is good. We are getting
somewhere.
Now it says speculate,
this is where you get to participate,
on the hkl values that if expressed
as h squared plus k squared plus l
squared would generate the sequence
of the clear fractions column.
And remember what you have to go on.
You have that set of simple cubic,
face-centered cubic, body-centered
cubic. What set of hkl's would give
you this? Well,
what sum of integer squares would
give you three?
I wonder. Maybe 1,
,1. How about 4?
And so you can see what is going on
here. This I have gotten from the
theta, and this is my speculation,
just trying. And now here is the
punch line. Compute for each theta
the value of this.
The sine squared theta over h
squared plus k squared plus l
squared. And,
if you get a constant,
bingo, you must have hit the jackpot.
Sine squared theta is this.
H squared plus k squared plus l
squared is square root
of 3. That is 0.0477.
You do it for the next one,
the next one and next one allowing
for experimental error.
I have a constant. What does that
say? It says that my speculation of
what the hkl's are is good.
It is self-consistent. And what do
I know? Those are either all even
or all odd. That is the sequence
for face-centered cubic.
So, on this basis, I can say that I
have something that is
face-centered cubic.
I am happy about that.
But, furthermore, what else can I
get? Well, I know the lambda value
and I know this thing.
This is that constant there.
What I can do is take this constant
and plug it into this equation.
And, furthermore, I can determine
that the a, whatever this crystal is,
is going to be lambda of copper k
alpha divided by 2 times the square
root of that constant.
And, if I plug in the numbers,
I get 3.53 angstroms. It is FCC.
It is 3.53 angstroms. If I look at
it and it looks metallic,
I am going to say it is nickel,
because I happen to know that nickel
has a lattice constant of 3.
3 angstroms. I know I have to do
some other things,
but certainly that makes me think
about whether I have nickel present.
Here is the gambit.
That is how you are going to solve
these problems.
You are going to go through this
set of operations.
Just to recap, if you are going to
look at this, simple cubic,
the hkl sequence is 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 8, 9, because there is no
sum of integers that will give you
seven if you sum squares of integers.
It will give you all the lines,
but this is h squared plus k squared
plus l squared in ascending value.
Body-centered cubic has to be 2,
4, 6, 8, 10, 12, 14, 16. But, when
you first do this,
you don't know because you divide by
the first sine squared.
And so you don't know it is 2,
4, 6, 8. You could end up with 1,
2, 3, 4. Now, don't we have a
problem? The simple cubic is going
1, 2, 3, 4 and body-centered cubic
is going 1, 2, 3, 4.
But watch this,
perseverance. Half of 10 is 5.
Half of 12 is 6. Half of 14 is 7.
Bingo. If you guessed that
something when you divide through
you get a sequence that gives you 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, you know that it
cannot be simple cubic because there
is no sum of integer squares that
gives you 7. This 7,
in fact, must be 14 divided by 2.
This is body-centered cubic.
Face-centered cubic is the easiest
one to pick off because it gives you
3, 4, 8, 11, 12.
I mean, I just need to see 3,
4 and I am done. I always check for
FCC first. Anyway,
that is how diffractometry works.
And it allows you to index crystals
and determine their crystal
structure. And,
more broadly speaking,
there is a database of all sorts of
minerals and compounds and so on.
Let's look at the second technique
which is called Laue diffraction
named after Max von Laue who got the
Nobel. He was the first person to
demonstrate x-ray identification of
crystal structure.
He got the Nobel in 1912 for this.
And in Laue we fix the angle, the
specimen is stationary and variable
wavelength radiation.
How do we get variable wavelength
radiation? Look at that spectrum up
there. You see the bremsstrahlung?
The bremsstrahlung gives you a
range of wavelengths.
How do we get monochromatic
radiation? How do we get
monochromatic x-rays?
And don't tell me we buy an x-ray
laser. How do we get monochromatic
x-rays? Well,
it is really cool.
What you do is take this
bremsstrahlung with
everything on it.
And you present it to a single
crystal. And then you park over
here, this is the entrance slit to
your diffractometer.
What will go through that entrance
slit? There is only one wavelength
that will go through that entrance
slit, and that is the wavelength
that satisfies the Bragg condition
for this lattice spacing at this
angle. What I can do is make a
single crystal monochromator that
basically takes this characteristic
spectrum on top of the
bremsstrahlung.
Sends that in.
I present a single crystal.
And there is only one wavelength of
light that will come out of here
that satisfies the Bragg condition
for this d spacing and this angle.
The single crystal acts as a
monochromator.
Very cool. This is called a single
crystal monochromator.
Just use Bragg's Law.
That is all. Well, in this case,
we take the whole mess, everything.
And here is what the specimen looks
like. The specimen goes into a
darkened box called a "camera
obscura." And what happens is I can
put the specimen on the front here.
This is some crystal, relatively
thin.
And I put film on the back.
I have film that is sensitive to
x-ray. Now I send the beam in.
This is white x-ray meaning it is
variable wavelength.
It is the whole spectrum.
And what happens is the white x-ray
interacts with the specimen and
shoots off at different angles
because I have different
initial wavelengths.
Each wavelength will be diffracted
at its own special angle.
What happens is we end up with a
spot pattern on the film.
Spot pattern is the output.
And the symmetry of the spot
pattern. I am not going to take you
into k space and so on,
but let me simply tell you that all
you need to appreciate at this point
is that the symmetry in the spot
pattern is imitative of the symmetry
in the crystal.
Let me say something about atomic
symmetry. And all we are talking
about here is rotational symmetry
because we are looking at something
on edge. For example,
if I gave you the 001 plane,
in a cubic crystal it looks like
this.
Now what I want to do is look at
rotation about a normal axis.
I am going to put a normal axis
right here at the center,
and I am going to rotate this.
I am going to ask you the question
through what angle do I have to
rotate this in order to get this
back? If you close your eyes and I
start rotating,
suppose I rotate it 45 degrees,
you open your eyes, you are going to
see that and know something
has moved.
How many degrees do I have to rotate
before I get this back?
90. If I rotate 90 degrees,
I will end up with this. These are
indistinguishable.
90 degrees is what I need to rotate.
And the crystallographers,
instead of talking about the angle
of rotation to restore what you are
looking at, they talk about fold.
And fold is simply 360 degrees
divided by this angle.
We say that this has four-fold
rotational symmetry.
Suppose I look at (011).
(011) is the diagonal. This is a
and this is square root of 2a.
And now, if I put an axis in the
center, through what angle do I have
to rotate before I get this back?
That is 180. This has two-fold
symmetry.
Finally, let's do (111).
The (111) plane looks like this.
And so, obviously, this you would
have to go through 120.
And this would exhibit three-fold
symmetry. For example,
remember I showed you that crystal
of the silicon,
single crystal silicon?
The single crystal silicon,
let's say we have cut it and we want
to find out what plane we cut it on.
Suppose we want to insure that we
have cut it so that the 111 plane is
parallel to the surface.
One way of determining this would
be to put the single crystal of
silicon into a Laue unit and
irradiate it. And,
if indeed we have the 111 plane,
we will see a spot pattern that
exhibits three-fold symmetry.
This allows us to do indexing.
The other thing we can do is put
the specimen on the back and have
the film on the front.
And we end up with what is known as
Laue backscatter.
Let's take a look at a few more
symmetries. This is going back to
some Escher prints.
I don't think I showed you this one
the other day.
What is that crystal structure?
It is either body-centered cubic or
face-centered cubic.
The two are the same in
two-dimensions.
This would exhibit four-fold
symmetry. This pattern exhibits
four-fold symmetry. This one.
Symmetry now. Three-fold symmetry.
120. I even tried it. I rotated
this. I actually programmed
Photoshop. I said rotate 120 degrees.
Bingo. Now you see.
Now, these are some Laue patterns
of various crystals.
This is what you see in the Laue
unit. Three different crystals here.
Let's look. What do we see?
How about this one? You won't be
able to tell the crystal structure.
All you can see is the pattern.
All you can ask from this is what is
the pattern? Which of these
symmetries do we have?
Is this four-fold, three-fold or
two-fold? This looks like four-fold,
90 degrees, pretty good.
This one here, well, you're right.
You can say six. It looks like 60
but, in fact, you need to go the
full and there are other reasons you
have to go into that.
This is two-fold.
Remember this?
This one is, you can see,
a 60 degree angle, but you can see
this has three-fold symmetry.
This gets back to somebody who said
60 degrees. You can see this
pattern requires because of the
basis here, in fact,
it requires 120 degrees.
What about this one? Exactly.
It is one-fold. This has
translational symmetry but no
rotational symmetry.
Obviously, if you go 90 degrees,
the dogs are going to be pointing up
and down.
If you go 180 degrees,
it is not going to work either.
This has rotational one-fold. I am
going to jump over this,
I think. I see we are getting close
to the end. Here is another
symmetry. This is the inverse of
the dogs. The dogs have no
rotational symmetry but
translational symmetry.
This pattern here has rotational
symmetry but no translational
symmetry.
It is called Penrose Tile.
And, in particular, there is the
rotational symmetry.
And how many turns do we go here?
It has five-fold symmetry. Five.
That is very weird.
Five-fold symmetry.
Now, this does not conform to any
rules of crystallography.
Such a pattern is called aperiodic.
We saw that you couldn't make
bathroom tile of this shape.
You would have to have other shapes
that would fit into the interstices
and so on. There is another one.
See, it fills to space, but you
have to add some extra.
But it has five-fold symmetry.
If you take this whole pattern and
rotate it 72 degrees,
you will get it back. It has
rotational symmetry.
Now I am going to show you something
that was really,
really unexpected.
So far we are over here in the top
left. We are studying ordered
solids which they have a unit cell,
they are periodic, and we call them
a crystal. And pretty soon we are
going to start studying disordered
solids which form glasses.
In 1982, there was a fellow by the
name of Dan Schechtman who was on
sabbatical from the Technion in
Israel. He was working down at the
National Bureau of Standards.
It was called NBS in those days.
It is now known as the National
Institute of Standards and
Technology. Sometimes you will see
this acronym NIST.
And they were down in Gaithersburg,
Maryland. And Schechtman and John
Kahn and coworkers were looking at a
set of alloys from the aluminum
manganese system,
and they were very highly ordered.
Over the range of composition, pure
aluminum is FCC.
Pure manganese has multiple crystal
structures.
The question is what happens when
you take something that is not
face-centered cubic and alloy it
with something that is face-centered
cubic? Well, initially aluminum
retains its face-centered cubic
crystal structure.
But, after a while,
you get to such a high manganese
level that the crystal structure
changes. And over certain ranges of
composition these alloys are
amorphous. They are glass formers.
But then came something totally
unexpected. When Schechtman
prepared the alloy that contained
25% manganese he got something
extremely weird in the x-ray
diffraction pattern.
He got five-fold symmetry in his
x-ray diffraction pattern.
Five-fold symmetry. This lax
translational symmetry,
it is aperiodic, these were termed
quasicrystals.
And this caused a storm in the
material science community.
In the mid 80s, all kinds of NSF
programs, Department of Defense
programs were funding research into
quasicrystals to try to figure out
they might have some
unique properties.
Maybe they have conductivities.
Maybe they have ductilities. Maybe
they have corrosion resistance that
is unknown in classical
face-centered,
body-centered, simple cubic alloys.
Here is one of Schechtman's Laue
patterns. Look at that.
That is so weird. There were jokes
about this. If you know the
geography, Gaithersburg is not far
from Washington.
Some people joked that this had
five-fold symmetry because the
research was funded by the Pentagon.
And this is really something.
These are the pages from
Schechtman's lab notebook.
April 8, 1982, aluminum 25%
manganese. And he is analyzing his
diffraction patterns and is going
nuts. He writes ten-fold
exclamation point triple.
And it was real.
It was very, very exciting.
That is what quasicrystals are
about. What you can see is how
using Laue you can infer that.
And then you have to go in and
determine what the lattice constant
is and so on. The last thing,
before you go. I ran out of time
last day. What is the connected
between 7-Up and lithium?
Before Mosley people referred to
things according to their atomic
mass. The atomic mass of lithium is
7. That is why it is 7.
I have this on good authority from
people in the lithium industry.
All right. Have a good weekend.